ان هناك نوع او فئه من الموظفين من
المسؤولين محميه من بعض
الجهات السياسيه
عندها قرار انه تتجاوز على المال العام
بذاك الحجم الذي حصل مع ضمانات الضريبيه
[موسيقى]
كلنا امل في دول الشقيقه والصديقه والعالم
كله اللي يتعاون مع العراق في مساله
استرداد الاموال والمطلوبين لانه
اغلب الفاسدين للاسف ذهبوا الى دول واخذوا
جنسيات للحمايه
[موسيقى]
اي اعتداء على الحدود مرفوض من اي دوله
وبعد الاعتداءات التي حصلت من
الجاره ايران وتركيا ورفضنا بمواقف رسميه
معلنه
وفيها اجراءات استدعاء سفرات من هذه
السياقات
[موسيقى]
والتيار الصدري نامل وجوده ومشاركته في كل
الفعاليات السياسيهم في خدمه البلد والشعب
هذه الحكومه حريصه على مد الجسور مع
الجميع
[موسيقى]
السعوديه دوله محوريه
استراتيجي للعراق ما بيننا من
الثقل والوجود على المستوى العربي
والاسلامي وكذلك ما لدينا من ثروات وموارد
كلها مزايا ممكن ان تؤسس للعراق والسعوديه
ان يكون يكون
محور
ومرتكز لنظام اقليمي مستقر
[موسيقى]